we're doing very well with China we're
talking to China we're not ready to make
a deal but we'll see what happens but
you know we've been hurt by China for
25-30 years nobody's done anything about
it and we have no choice but to do what
we're doing it's working out very well
as you know what we we called them on
manipulation and they brought their
numbers back and they brought it back
rapidly and they were able to do that
because they manipulate but that's how
it's called monetary manipulation not
good but what happened and what's
happening with China now we have an open
dialogue we'll see whether or not we
keep our meeting in September if we do
that's fine if we don't that's fine but
it's time that somebody does what we're
doing and I said the American taxpayer
is not paying for it we had a big day in
the stock market yesterday but the
American taxpayer is not paying for it
what shine is doing is by depressing
their currency and by pouring tremendous
amounts of money into their system
they're paying for it the prices have
not gone up so when the amount in fact
in some cases they've gone down because
the devaluation plus the money supply
the the amount of money that they pour
in which is a form of manipulation has
more than compensated for an increase in
price so as I said and everybody
questioned it in the case of China the
tariffs have been amazing with taking in
billions and billions of dollars now
China's had their works here in 35 years
now it was in 26 years but now it's in
35 years
I want them to do well but as of this
moment they're having the worst year
that they've had in many many years in
decades and really would just bring you
the system back into order we have all
the cards we're doing well our country's
doing fantastically well you look at
Europe they've got problems like the
biggest problem we have is the fact that
a lot of other continents frankly but a
lot of other countries are not doing
well but we're doing great and we
continue to do great our companies are
poised they have a lot of cash our
system is beautiful
I think I could but I don't think I'll
be there I have a great relationship
with the NRA they supported me very
early and that's been a great decision
they made we have justice Cavanaugh we
have justice courses and they feel very
strongly about the Second Amendment the
NRA has made a great decision in
supporting me and nobody else would have
one aside from everything else I have a
very good relationship by I'll change it
I have a great relationship with the NRA
I have a lot of respect for the people
of the NRA and I have already spoken
them on numerous occasion numerous
occasions and frankly we need
intelligent background checks okay this
is an equation of NRA Republican or
Democrat I will tell you I spoke to
Mitch McConnell yesterday he's totally
on board he said I've been waiting for
your call he is totally on board
I spoke to Senators that in some cases
people are friends of mine but pretty
hard line senators hard line and when I
say that I say that in a positive way
hard line on the Second Amendment and
they understand we don't want insane
people mentally ill people bad people
dangerous people we don't want guns in
the hands of the wrong people I think
that the Republicans are going to be
great and lead the charge along with the
Democrats I spoke yesterday de Nancy
Pelosi with a great talk I spoke to
Chuck Schumer we had a great call and
Chuck Schumer
she loves my China policy as you
probably know I said I can't believe it
you actually like something that I'm
doing
he said not like love so Chuck Schumer's
he's great on the China situation which
we are winning and winning big and China
wants to do something but I'm not ready
to do anything yet 25 years of abuse I'm
not ready so fast so we'll see how that
works out but one day on the background
checks on background checks we have
tremendous support for really
common-sense sensible import background
check
okay
[Music]
time goes by I don't think I'm different
but I think the Senate is different I
think other people in the house are
different I think that people that maybe
had their arm up a couple of years ago
maybe they feel differently I don't
think I feel any differently I think
with a lot of success that we have I
think I have a greater influence now
over the Senate and over the house I
think we can get something really good
done I think we can have some really
meaningful background checks we don't
want people that have mentally ill
people that are are sick we don't want
them having guns who does well we'll see
where the NRA will be but we have to
have meaningful background checks you
know in the case of in both cases it's
possible they wouldn't have been caught
but in the one case we also have to talk
about age because he did things that
were very very bad in Ohio in Dayton he
did some things that were really bad his
school knew about it when he turned 18
everything was expunged we're going to
have to get rid of that because you
can't have that barrier if they would
have had that fair they would have been
able to see but because he was a minor
who was expunged we're gonna have to get
rid of that barrier I think this I think
a lot of really leaning
things on background checks will take
place including red flags including a
lot of other very very important item
that the Republicans are looking at it
very seriously and I really believe that
the NRA I've spoken to a numerous times
they're really good people they great
Patriots they love our country they love
our country so much and frankly I really
think they're gonna get their own
[Music]
I had a good talk with Wayne and I like
Wayne and you know as you know they
supported me very early far earlier than
anybody thought possible especially me
not being a politician and that support
has paid off we now have two Supreme
Court justices that are phenomenal
Cavanaugh and George Dorsey and I mean
they're phenomenal
people and the big believers in the
Second Amendment which Wayne is also in
which I am I mean there's been there's
been no president that feels more
strongly about the Second Amendment that
I do however we need meaningful
background check so that sick people
don't get gun I think in the end I think
in the end Wayne and the NRA will either
be there or maybe will be a little bit
more neutral and that would be okay too
the NRA has over the years taken a very
very tough stance and everything and I
understand that you know it's a slippery
slope
they think you approve one thing and
that leads to a lot of bad things I
don't agree I think I think we can do
meaningful very meaningful background
checks I want to see it happen so I've
got a lot of support and I also have the
support of other people on the other
side and I think
Democrats and Republicans have a chance
to really
the reason is because you have to go in
you can't let anybody know otherwise
when you get there nobody will be there
but a big factor is to let people
outside of the country that want to come
in legally and illegally into our
country where they come in in caravans
with a surge the border which by the way
we have the numbers way down right now
as you see because Mexico is done a
fantastic job Mexico has 26,000 soldiers
right now on the border they have been
fantastic because of the Paris but I
don't care what it's because Mexico that
I'll be calling the president at a
certain point I just hope they keep it
up because if the Democrats were James
to love but I was thinking about putting
together as you know with the gun
situation so we have immigration and we
have let's say some of the things we're
talking about right now you having
together but I want people to know that
if they come into the United States
illegally they're getting out they're
going to be brought out and this serves
as a very good deterrent if people come
into our country illegally they're going
out they're not coming in illegally in
saying we have bad laws they may get in
although we're being very tough but they
may get it but it doesn't matter because
they're going out and when people see
what they saw yesterday and like they
will see for a long time they know that
the next day
I think they really like you know it's
really amazing because african-american
unemployment just came out very recently
the lowest in history it's the best the
best numbers in history African
employment on Hispanic and Asian to have
four people working today than ever work
in the history of our country less like
the criminal justice reform which
President Obama could not get approved
which the media never talks about if
President Obama that criminal justice
reform done it would be front-page
stories all over the place I got it done
I think that african-americans
appreciate it so I get that at the best
unemployment numbers I have the best of
women others for a lot of people but for
African American American number one
that we've ever had one other thing we
did aside from criminal justice reform
opportunities um and they are doing
unbelievably well and you'll see that
and you've already seen it but
Opportunity Zones and the biggest
delenn to the White House that would be
the president of Ukraine led to Mirza
left
do you plan to wipe to the White House
and war to destroy watch where he on how
to communicate with leather recording
scooped up the conflict in eastern
Ukraine I think he's going to make a
deal with President Putin and he will be
invited to the White House and with
opposed to seeing if he's already been
invited to the right after he watch to
come and I think he will he's a very
reasonable guy he wants to see pieces
Ukraine and I think he will be
yeah his comments look look Joe is not
playing with a full deck
we made that comment I said whoa I
thought because I was on something I had
a television
I joined coming Joe Biden is not playing
with a full deck this is not somebody
you can have as your president but if he
got the nomination I'd be thrilled we're
looking at that right now we have a lot
of these companies coming in a little
while as you know we're going to be
merged up with them they're treating
conservatives very unfairly Hollywood I
don't call them the elites I think the
elites are people they go after in many
cases but Hollywood is really terrible
you talk about races Hollywood is races
what they're doing with the kind of
movies they're putting out it's actually
very dangerous for our country what
Hollywood is doing is a tremendous
disservice to our country we have now in
a little while all of the heads of the
biggest companies coming in and we're
going to talk to them they treat
conservatives Republicans totally
different than they treat others and
they can't do that devalue the US dollar
we don't have to we have such a strong
dollar the problem is our dollars at a
level that it makes it hard but the
advantage to doing what we have is money
is pouring in because we have the safest
currency in the world we have the
standard of the world but because it's
so strong it's gotten so strong because
other countries that problem
makes it harder for a manufacturer so if
we lowered the interest rate by the
Federal Reserve that would automatically
bring down the dollar a little bit and
it would make it easier for Caterpillar
and these companies but we have the
greatest currency in the world no I
wouldn't do are you thinking of
canceling the great talks next month
with China so China wants to settle this
deal they've had the worst year that
they've had in many many decades and
it's getting only words thousands of
companies - leaving China they would
like to make a deal I'm not ready to
make a deal maybe I would for what
happened right now right now the talks
are scheduled in September whether or
not we're talking about China whether or
not they're canceled we'll see look as I
said our people are not paying for these
billions and billions of dollars that
came in 16 billion of which I gave to
the farmers because they were targeted
by China and that's just a small
fraction of what we think it is so they
are not because what China's been doing
is they're a currency manipulator
they've manipulated the value of their
currency and that's where the money
comes and also they put tremendous money
into the system so you look prices have
not risen our people have not paid so
all of these guys that say Oh Trump
hooked up they don't know what they're
talking about now China's unique that
doesn't mean it happens with other
countries it probably doesn't but the
prices have not gone up in fact we have
virtually no inflation in our country if
the Federal Reserve would swing bring
down interest rate over a period of time
I would love to see a point or even a
little bit more than that if they would
stop quantitative tightening we have a
rocket ship
I mean we're doing well without it but
we're being handcuffed by the Federal
Reserve because they would stop that it
would
well I hope that South Korea and I hope
that Japan not getting along with each
other you know they're supposed to be
allies they should come kinda puts us in
a very difficult position South Korea
and Japan are fighting all the time
they've got to get along because it puts
us in a very bad position with that
being said I got a very beautiful letter
from Kim jong-un yesterday was delivered
when he was hand-delivered it was a very
positive I'd love to give it to you
I think we'll have another bathing he
really wrote a beautiful three page
right from top to bottom a really
beautiful letter and maybe I'll release
the results of the letter but it was a
we're not going to do business with
huawei we're not doing business with and
I really made the decision it's much
simpler not to do any business with
Huawei so we're not doing business to it
why wait that doesn't mean we won't
agree to something if and when we make a
great deal but we're not going to be
doing business with Wallen Admiral
highly respected great leader he's
acting right now you did a great job
I like subordinate very much I think
that over a period of time I'm in no
rush because we have a great acting I
spoke to Senator burr about different
people he's head of intelligence and I'm
working together with better to burn the
whole committee I want to get somebody
that everybody can really come together
with so will i like pete hoekstra ladies
great he's doing a fantastic job in the
Netherlands right now that's the job
that everybody wants DNI
but I'm dealing I'm dealing with the
committee I'm dealing with really
Senator bear a lot and we'll come up
with somebody that's great we have a lot
of choice a lot of people concerned that
they're not getting along with each
other they have to get along with each
other but they don't get along what are
we doing they have to get along with HR
30 but South Korea and Japan have to sit
down and get along with each other
otherwise what are we all doing
so Poland has been a great great friend
of ours they were offered to build a
military base and the cost of many
billions of dollars no money put up by
the United States whatsoever they walked
in to fund our troops and lots of other
things the way it should be not just
stupid deals that we made with all these
other countries to take advantage of it
so Poland has been terrific and we're
going to be going to Poland very soon
I'm sure you're going to be going with
us I had a great experience in Poland
the left on my West in fact some of you
actually said this reaches one of the
best ever made in Europe by an American
president hard to believe that you
actually said that when you said that I
was like in a state of shock a great
friend of mine is a very successful guy
we were competitors but friends in real
estate in New York in the old days he's
a great guy he is by the way I think
he's probably more inclined to be a
liberal if you want to know the truth
but he likes me he respects me we're
doing a fundraiser then we're doing
another fundraiser with another friend
of mine and I understand the fundraiser
was totally sold out and it's very
successful
I don't think I think it just makes
Steve much hotter I explained I didn't
sleep over yet I'll see him in a while
the controversy makes Steve Ross hotter
figure that out of about a week but he's
very happy he's got a very successful a
lot of people are going we have two
fundraisers want to see what is another
gentleman and I guess they're going to
raise 11 or 12 billion million dollars
you supported by long guns at the age of
25 I'm not talking about anything
specific I can tell you this tremendous
goodwill but meaningful I took it about
meaningful and that word meaningful
background check so that sick and
demented people don't carry around you
have to remember and I've said it the
big mental illness problem and the gun
doesn't pull the trigger a mind the sick
mind wasn't right
we want to take that out of you
so we're looking at you we mentioned we
actually if you look there are many
bills that have been put in over a
period of four or five years right
they went nowhere but there's never been
a president like resident drunk
I don't think we'll need to I'm a
leadership is dealing along with me
right now by the time you call them back
they're gonna be back anyway I don't
think we'll need to call them back I
think we'll have a very good package by
the time they come back and they can
start debating and voting on it then so
I really don't think for the extra
little time it matters leadership is
doing a really good job Mitch McConnell
Kevin man chest open then see Pelosi
yesterday I spoke with Chuck Schumer
yesterday there's a lot of goodwill
about this issue
I don't think so no I think we have a
lot of support I mean I'm very fortunate
in the Republican Party I'm at 94
percent approval rating so that helps
but I have a great relationship with the
Republican senators and I really think
they're they're looking for me to make
give them a signal and we're gonna have
great support and I think we'll have to
support from the Democrats off
no no I never said what I'm saying now
what I'm saying what I said there you
had tremendous opposition for many
people on both sides I see a better
feeling right now toward getting
something meaningful doesn't meaningful
and we think through things have to
parkland but it wasn't to the same level
that I'm talking about now you know we
did do to fix Nick's and various other
things so we did do a lot of work after
Berkeley but I think we have now a
chance to do something really much more
meaningful having to do having to do as
you know with background check
well my message to young children going
back to school is go and really study
hard and someday you'll grow up and
maybe be President of the United States
or do something else that's fantastic
they have nothing to fear they have
nothing to worry about in addition we're
in constant contact with state with
state government and they are really
doing a great job we have this so much
better than it was two and a half years
ago two and a half years ago when I came
in it was really not a good situation I
think we have a very very good system
right now that doesn't mean that there's
not going to be some crazy person but
that's what we want to do we want to
take the guns out of the hands of crazy
demented sick people
we're not looking at that right now
we're really looking at very beautiful
background check I think it's going to
happen this great great support but
we're looking at very very meaningful
background check
[Music]
well Admiral as you know McGuire Admiral
McGuire is a very talented man he's a
great leader as an admiral was always a
great leader he is a man who was
respected by everybody and he's going to
be them for a period of time who knows
maybe he gets the job but he'll be he'll
be there for a period of time maybe a
longer period of time than we think
we'll see we're dealing with senator
Burr we're dealing with the committee
we're dealing with probably 9 or 10
people that want the job very much you
know you know the name of almost every
one of them they're truly outstanding
everybody wants DNI everybody wants him
and I will say that the Admiral is such
a great choice from the standpoint of
now and maybe he goes further we'll see
what happens
but we're dealing with the committee and
Senator Farah yep
people all of whom you know highly
respected people will be making the
decision in the not-too-distant
Eugene Scalia is a highly respected
lawyer in Washington his father as you
know was the great great great Supreme
Court justice even the people with not
his views would say he was a great
gentleman a great man
Eugene Scalia Dean Scalia has had a
fantastic career as you know he's our
appointment for labor secretary I think
so far scan received very well he is a
very one of them one of the finest minds
and lawyers in Washington and I will say
so far that's been received very well
yeah he gave me a great letter I would
love to give you but I don't know I
don't think would be appropriate but it
was a very personal letter it was a
great letter he talked about what he's
doing he's not happy with the testing
it's a very small testing that we did
but he wasn't happy with the testing he
put that in the letter but he also sees
a great future for North Korea and so
we'll see how it all works out in the
meantime I say it again
there have been no nuclear tests the
missile tests of Oban short-range no
ballistic missile tests no long-range
missile we got back and we're getting
back as we speak we're getting back a
lot of our fallen heroes you know that
they're coming back into and through
Hawaii and we got back to our hostages
so I thought the letter I just got it
yesterday it was hand-delivered and it
wasn't touched by anybody they literally
take it from North Korea to my office we
have a system the old-fashioned system
you don't have to worry about leaks
something nice about that sensor
now he wasn't he wasn't happy with the
guests the Morgans
the war games on the other side with the
United States and and as you know I've
never liked it either I've never liked
it I've never been a fan you know why I
don't like paying for it we should be
reimbursed for it and I've told that to
South Korea but I don't like it either
but I said do this because this was a
big test this was a turnover of various
areas to South Korea I like that because
that's what should happen well I can't
imagine that but if they did that we
just reciprocated we are a very
reciprocal nation with me as the head
when somebody does something negative to
us in terms of a country we do it to
them look our country has been taken
advantage of by foreign countries even
allies including allies and in many
cases more than anybody else we've been
taken advantage of for many many years
and it stops it stop
in your view mr. president there's colin
kaepernick could get an opportunity to
play in the NFL
only if he's good enough yeah if he's
good enough yeah I'm not getting why why
would he play if he's good enough and I
think if he was good enough I know the
owners I know Bob Griff I'm there's so
many of the owners if he's good enough
in China so if he's good enough I know
these people they would sign them in a
heartbeat they will do anything they can
to win game so I'd like to see it
frankly I'd love to see Kaepernick come
in if he's good enough but I don't want
to see him coming in because somebody
thinks it's a good PR mode if he's good
enough he will be well the global
markets are not as good as our market
our market has been really good but
always it's never positive well then you
could say it puts us in an even better
position
I knew it differently I mean most people
would say that's a bad thing I would say
the fact that other countries aren't
doing really well China in particular
China's doing horribly horribly first
time that anyone can remember they are
having a year like they've never had
almost you know go back 30 40 years
they're having one of the worst years
ever the numbers are phony they're not
doing six points do they're doing a
totally different what do you think
they're doing maybe neutral
you're gonna refer maybe even
I don't think it helps personally I
don't like it when they do it because I
am not any of those things I think it's
a disgrace and I think it shows how
desperate the Democrats are look right
now I'm working with the Democrats for
meaningful background check that's the
big thing hopefully we can do something
but so I don't want to focus too much in
that I will say this for them to throw
out the race word again racist racist
Rachel that's all they use to anybody
they call Nancy Pelosi a racist she's
not a racist they call anybody a racist
when they run out of cards I'm winning
in the polls they're desperate
they've got lousy candidate they've got
bad candidates I mean I watch the
debates I mean I look I live well I mean
Joe Biden can't answer a simple question
something something go going wrong with
him I mean the only the only thing is I
mean a lot of people think that he was
the one that wanted Bob Muller to
testify because it made Joe look
intelligent okay I think my base
realized very much on common sense and
they rely on me in terms of telling them
what's happening
I think meaningful background checks I
don't just say background checks like
this we pass background checks a number
of times
meaning the Democrat but everybody knew
they were
that I think meaningful background chips
are real positive politically I can't
tell you you know I don't know good
better a difference
I don't care politically I don't want to
have crazy people having guns
[Music]
you